basics basics I don't even know how to
pronounce it and it's pretty awful
acronym as you're about to discover what
is it it stands for the building yeah
yeah that's B's you even though feet or
whatever physics doesn't under
composites under building sustainability
sustainability index so this is a way to
score buildings according to how well
they adhere to sustainability guidelines
now when you see that word
sustainability what kinds of things come
to mind
okay good we want to make sure that
things are gonna walk right we're going
to use it yeah hooray our children to do
now we're going to use your sources in a
way that student effectively so that
we're not going to like it a flow
through the environment in what ways in
what ways would a building mainly being
sustainable or not sustainable consult
with a live example okay all right so
think about this sustainability and sort
of marking a religion shorthand for
environmental sustainability so so we're
thinking about things such as if they
have a designer going and the design
building has a really big influence
Eliana the design of the building has a
really big influence on things like how
much water on that building consumed how
much electricity it consumes those
differently resources
that a building will consume and will
conceive differently depending on the
way that it's constructed
okay so for example with regard to water
doesn't building have savory water
attacks where you wanna taste attached
or like the rain rolls off and then
where did it go we're now under mostly
into the drain in fact um in fact if you
look closely you can see our gutters
because they're so massive our gutters
actually have our release valves in them
to notice that which kind of makes them
funny because god is are actually
supposed to in general terms stop that
happening so when you're walking on the
side of gaudy water is not just gushing
on but because they are surface area of
our ruse is so large it needs to go lies
in just overflow so things like our
where the water is going so like are
there rainwater collection tanks but not
electricity what would make something
good it's hose electricity or for okay
the obvious one is solar
what else what else would affect the
electricity usage of a building okay so
for example in this room in this very
room at active this block right you guys
know when it hits a certain time will
happen to the lights yeah ah okay good
we're getting to a few other things here
so then you talk about a natural light
and natural ventilation so I don't know
how many of you have noticed this but if
you hear out the window and not that one
but that one right
please notice that if you actually walk
through TR there's some lights but
usually they're off we will learn how
they live it's not Windows it's an
interior it's a skylight right inside
the tubes right there which is why
that's what is so bright so all of these
kinds of factors contribute so that's
what it is the building sustainability
Alexis who does it apply to if your
building is sort of well suppose it has
a very very poor
let's just state ability in depth is
that a good idea just to knock it down
probably not because that's not going to
be necessarily sustainable either unless
it's like a train wreck of a building
and it's you know really disastrous most
footings that he already existed I just
sort of left where they are however if
you've got new dwellings okay
for instance in fact if you find I a lot
of office blocks in the city they
actually have a whole bunch of greenery
around them like within the building in
on the edges because that's part of you
know again sustainability factors so
this affects news photos however we're
all interesting because obviously if
you're bad you're building for bad index
that's bad . whether you've got a new
building or not okay so how do we how
does it work
and now you need to look at your
device's okay now I hope your device is
there let's let's walk through this now
there's so much information here that
it's really important we don't lose the
forest for the trees
so just flies up for a second I want
every pictures it is they don't know do
not do this that's the syllabus I'm glad
some people recognize it okay so you can
see we're in the photo study on
resources energy and sustainability as
they're surprised giving them we're
looking into the index right now I want
you to have a look down this is sort of
dot point west okay how far do you have
to get down before you start in
mathematics if said last two just last
two now the reason why I want to make
sure that you have a clear idea of what
these blocks you are is the best this is
a big deal it's a really important
social and register the structure and
lots of information to it it's really
easy just to get what we are looking at
it from a mathematical standpoint not
from a like we could spend a whole year
studying this and making sure we wrap
our heads around it is probably not
magnetic
but geography so we are going to look at
the mathematical part of it which means
these two things
I'm exchanges taboos blacksmith identify
the issues addressed in the message eg
areas like water federal culture and
energy we just started to talk about
that we're going to look at that in more
details with lesson there is second last
one this is really where this comes in
calculate building sustainability
measurements based on the requirements
of the basics can you write that down
for me this is an important phrase don't
you don't need the whole thing but
calculate building sustainability
measures can you write that phrase down
and then I will tell you what it means
this is what you're going to get asked
to do in a paper write a sustainability
measure sustainability measure it's
something like how much power does this
building use when you switch on all of
its lights for a normal business day how
much is it going to consume over the
course of that day month young that is a
sustainability vision right or how much
water it is is a part of what is it
going to consume in its you know current
environment how much rain is going to
consume offset that that is a
sustainability measure so as an example
I think I the last year later fourth
lesson
thank you the question they got posed in
relation there was something simple like
you know soldier has ability in order to
meet his requirements for the water
sustainability measure there's an
important number I will just write down
so there are different water which is
40% that's a really important number for
you today one of the requirements of the
massive certification is that if you put
a new dwelling or a new structure it
needs to use 40% less I don't know this
is potable approachable it looks like
it's putting your stuff in half word
rules are 40% less portable water use
versus an average building to a fall
faster
just introduced okay so that number
exists on the website you can go hunt it
down later on but the point is we want
to design the building such that you
think less one of them you've used
before so the question said silencer is
using this much water yet again this is
how much these bills have been going if
you add all four quarters but he needs
to hit this 40% less benchmark how much
less water is he going to have to use if
this year you use however many number of
kilometres okay so you see how the
calculation is involved you're going to
have to work out or what is 40% less how
am I going to meet that requirement and
then how much am I gonna have to reduce
my current usage by so in some ways it's
less a question about all of this and
that's really a percentage question
that's all it is okay but that's because
percentages are used for all the time
and they come up when people are trying
to get their certificate for this you
are going to have to do this this is the
least mathematical part of it but it
doesn't really make much sense to
calculate numbers if you don't know what
those numbers are about so identify the
issues address that was why I said all
of this this is kind of in a nutshell
that's morally tough work which is why
your website